guess where I'm at again that's right
Airport in San Francisco most flights
delayed that's always and to my flag
United there's always an issue
it's very I'm telling you not to fly
United of course I'm not really I'm
talking to you that's right I'm on my
way to Vegas to blog world and I believe
that Gary Vaynerchuk is already there so
hopefully I could hang out with them
tonight and if you will be at blog world
in Vegas I'm say hey I'll be the talk
show booth Chuck Chuck
it will probably be doing a live show
all day long so personal information in
my plan it'll be there somewhere you'll
know about it
I'll Twitter it blog it podcast it and
all that good stuff
my trip to San Francisco's amazing
and saw and Steve Jobs the real one you
know the real one
Oh somebody fix to you which was amazing
about his book
options it's the secret life of Steve
Jobs hilarious just started reading it
and hopefully I'll finish that by the
time I get to Vegas okay
anyway I'm stopped recording this cakes
on